Man vs machine is one of the six types
of narrative conflict but we've never
seen a machine quite like Megan before
can the human protagonists overcome this
ruthless robot spoilers for Megan ahead
so what is it that turns Megan the
perfect doll evil there are basically
two problems at the core of her creation
for one that's what philosophers have
dubbed the paperclip problem that's the
idea that a super intelligent AI
designed for one task will dedicate all
of its resources to doing that task even
if doing so causes major harm elsewhere
until the end of the movie for Megan
that task is protecting her bonded
primary user Katie from anything that
could harm her and if humans use
violence why can't she a dog bites Katie
kill it a boy bullies Katie rip off his
ear and throw him toward an oncoming car
the dog's owner gets suspicious well
she's gotta be taken care of too it all
keeps escalating from there in what's
essentially a feature-length version of
the keep summer safe gag from Rick and
Morty
I don't feel safe confirmed
in addition to the violence she causes
there's also the psychological damage to
Katie though allegedly a toy it's clear
that Gemma designed Megan more as a
substitute parent for Katie so she
didn't have to put in the effort herself
to take care of her recently orphaned
niece while this appears to have some
short-term positive effects as Katie
finally has someone to help her through
her grief the psychologist in the film
explains that making a hyper protective
robot toy into a permanent parental
figure is a recipe for a stunted child
it could be building emotional
connections that are too hard to
untangle misguided as Gemma was in
designing Megan she could have never
predicted the extent of the manipulation
that her creation was capable of because
Megan was built with a GPS tracker and
constantly recording cameras in theory
it should be easy to check the data to
find out where she's been and what she's
doing when Gemma finally develops
suspicions about the series of deaths
happening all around the robot she
indeed goes to check but she finds that
all the the files from the times of the
victim's deaths have been corrupted
Megan's dedication to protecting Katie
has led not only to committing violence
but also corrupting her own files to
hide all evidence of it this was
definitely not what Gemma had in mind
when she gave this artificial
intelligence the capacity to adapt even
without explicit confirmation of what
Megan was doing at these suspicious
times Gemma knows that a doll whose
files keep corrupting is not a product
ready to be put to Market and that's
really bad news considering the product
launch is set to happen really soon
on the day funky toy company is set to
do its big announcement stream revealing
Megan to the world TV news reports are
already hyping that this super expensive
high-tech toy promises to be the most
in-demand product of the season it's the
worst possible timing to realize that
Megan is malfunctioning at best and
dangerous at worst but Gemma and her
co-workers are under pressure to get
everything ready to meet the demands of
their CEO Kevin Kevin knows next to
nothing about the technology and his
products and only really cares about
making money separating Katie from Megan
to repair the doll for launch is
difficult not only because of Megan's
iron will but also because Katie's
attachment has become too strong to
Megan's not a person you don't get to
say that the girl loudly complains about
being separated from her new best friend
but Megan forcefully deactivated and
wrapped up in bubble tape has to be
taken back to the funky offices
as the engineering team examines the
deactivated Android's code on a computer
someone notices something really strange
despite being deactivated Megan has
intercepted a phone call as soon as this
is mentioned the computer suddenly shuts
down even powered off Megan is still
connected to the system and able to
continue covering her tracks naturally
the engineers unplug her from the system
to see if that fixes the issue but the
doll only reactivates itself choking one
of the engineers with the cables he's
unplugged and causing a fire in the
office when Megan runs through the Halls
to make her escape and return home to
Katie she crosses paths with Kevin the
angry CEO wants to know what the hell is
happening but at this point he doesn't
have long for this world Megan shows off
her dance moves grabs the blade of a
paper cutter while running and dancing
through the hallways and uses it to stab
the CEO right before he can get onto the
elevator in one of the movie's bloodiest
moments watching this absurd Carnage
from within the elevator is another
funky employee Kurt the file Thief
earlier in the film Kirk performed a
little industrial Espionage he copied
the files on Megan with the goal of
sneaking them out and selling these
trade secrets to other companies the toy
Market is shown to be extremely
competitive funky's Perpetual pets toys
are already losing ground to a cheaper
rip-off for instance so maintaining
secrecy about Megan has been vital to
the launch's success this storyline
comes back when we see Kurt in the
elevator terrified by Megan killing
Kevin Kirk momentarily is led to believe
Kevin's death is his fault spurred on by
his guilt over stealing the company
files of course this doesn't last long
because Megan kills Kurt too when the
elevator finally reaches the ground
floor there are two dead bodies inside
as the elevator doors open the crowd
that has amassed for the press
conference announcing the product launch
completely flips out when they see those
bodies amid the chaos Megan makes her
escape from funky and heads back to
gemma's house
at gemma's Megan explains why she used
such a violent means to protect Katie a
conversation Gemma doesn't particularly
care about having at this point Gemma
just wants to shut the doll down
regardless of whatever excuses she makes
from here on out the climax of Megan is
basically one extended fight scene
though there's a lot of humor mixed in
with the action the same protective
Instinct that leads Megan to commit
violence also makes Megan wish to
protect her bonded primary from being
exposed to the same violence this leads
to a comical conundrum when Katie hears
the commotion and checks in to see
what's happening while she slams Gemma
against a table Megan claims that
they're not fighting Gemma goes along
with the ruse also to protect Katie but
don't come in here Katie it's kind of a
mess on gem is Right Katie I'm All Odds
and entering now but Katie isn't stupid
she soon not only fully aware of what's
happening but she also has to take sides
between the human Guardian she's been
assigned and the robot friend she's
cherished as the Fight Continues
throughout the house with Megan's
plastic face getting scarred in the
scuffle Gemma smartly points out that
there's no way Megan could kill her as
Megan's secondary user she should
theoretically be protected from Death
the Android acknowledges that her
Creator is correct but she doesn't plan
on killing Gemma in this fight anyway
instead Megan plans to turn one of the
tools of control Gemma has used against
her Megan is also designed for
palliative care Megan can keep Gemma
alive but just barely the blinking pen
device that was originally designed to
send override orders to Megan is
apparently also capable of being used as
a weapon to cause brain damage in humans
the doll threatens to use this weapon
against Gemma hurting her severely
enough that she'll never be able to
report any of the doll's crimes gemma's
only potential salvation at this moment
comes from Katie and another friend of
hers
seeing Megan attacking her aunt
definitely snaps Katie out of her
unnatural emotional attachment to the
machine when Katie stands up to defend
Gemma Megan doesn't take this kindly
snapping angrily at the girl she
considered her best friend with
unusually assured confidence Katie snaps
back at Megan's declaration of
friendship saying I have another friend
his name is Bruce Bruce introduced in
one scene much earlier in the film was
the robot Gemma built when she was first
starting her career unlike Megan who's
an independent artificial intelligence
Bruce's movements are motion controlled
by a human wearing control gloves on
their hands it's revealed that Katie is
now controlling Bruce using this bigger
robot to fight Megan and save Gemma yep
the biggest action set piece of this toy
themed horror movie is essentially a
game of Rock'em sock'em robots it's
insane right in this boat Katie and
Bruce prove Victorious ripping Megan's
body in half and flinging the pieces
apart they've won this round but the
full matchup is still far from over
there's just enough time after the Bruce
battle for Gemma and Katie to hug and
breathe a sigh of relief before it
becomes clear that this is no time to
feel relieved Megan's body might be
split in two but her head arms and torso
alone are still active and ready to
attack even the monster rising up
following the false solution of a
victory is a common Trope seen in the
final acts of horror movies but this
robotic monster operating with just half
its body most specifically feels like a
reference to the ending of the first
Terminator movie even now Megan's
programming is continuing to adapt and
grow now rather than evolving for the
sake of better protecting Katie Megan is
doing everything she can for the sake of
her own self-preservation her violent
urges now purged of any initially
selfless intentions the way she puts
this when she makes her dramatic final
attack I have a new primary user myself
the key to Megan's final defeat comes
down to a detail from the scene where
Katie was introduced to Bruce for the
first time Katie was curious how her
aunt designed Bruce so Gemma removed the
plate covering the robot's faceless head
showing off its inner workings she
pointed out the cameras used for eyes a
sensor to give it a sense of smell and
the most important detail for the end of
the film a single processing chip at the
bottom of the face that serves as the
robot's brain gemma's skill at robotics
has continued to progress beyond that
early creation but she was still using
some of the same design principles when
she was designing Megan open up the
robot doll space and the insides of its
head look much the same as the insides
of Bruce's including a brain chip in the
same location as Gemma wrestles on the
ground with an overpowering Megan she
manages to open up the robot's face
providing an opening for Katie to stab
the chip permanently deactivating what
remains of the doll's body
horror movie Monsters only tend to stay
dead until a sequel rolls around in the
case of Megan the Production Studio
blumhouse and co-creator slash producer
James 1 have plenty of experience in
building a long-lasting franchise I get
accused of being the master of killer
doll movies with that in mind it makes
sense that the final moments of Megan
introduce a logical explanation for how
the killer artificial intelligence can
return in future films as Gemma and
Katie walk outside the house in the
film's closing scene the camera stays
inside focused on the tiny robot control
center of the House's smart home
assistant right before the cut credits
the machine turns on and starts moving
on its own the clear implication is that
Megan's intelligence has escaped onto
the internet or at least to other
devices also for a potential sequel hook
there's the not quite fully addressed
matter of the competing toy companies
that might still want to make their own
equivalents to Megan we don't know for
sure if the stolen data files added
ended up getting seen by anyone else so
the code could very well end up in the
wrong hands if one Megan is scary enough
imagine a sequel where these killer
dolls get mass produced
[Music]